well hooker afternoon everybody and
welcome to the Thursday October 3rd 2019
in our session our seminar series on
edge computing whether Asia and the
United States are going to go in
different directions
and for our first of the guest speakers
this week I'm delighted that we can have
really one of the very few people in the
world who is qualified to talk about not
only 5g network technology but their
adoption and all of the different kinds
of international things going on about
5g our speaker this week is Professor
olga swami
paulo Raj and professor Paul Raj started
off being a really famous inventor in
the United States actually was in the
Indian Navy for 30 years and developed
technologies so professor Paul Raj
developed a technology that allows
multiple cell antennas to be used both
at the transmission side and the
reception side for wireless
communications and so his work is really
a critical part of all sulfa networks
now he's the author of more than 400
research papers he has two textbooks
he's a co-inventor on 79 US patents he
is in the United States Patent Office
inventors Hall of Fame he received the
Marconi prize from the Marconi
foundation and he received the Alexander
Graham Bell Prize from the I Triple E so
the technical qualifications are
absolutely you know without question he
has also found it and I think him to
exit to startup companies in the kind of
wireless communication space one of
which was acquired by Intel and one of
which was acquired by Broadcom he has
also had a very company I'm sorry I
missed that one that was acquired by HP
II in 2016 so professor Paul Raj is very
active on the international stage it's
really hard to catch him when he's
actually at Stanford we're delighted
that you could come by and talk to us
about the promise of G Network thanks
very much thank you professor - yeah can
everybody hear me good it's an honor to
be in the seminar I haven't spoken this
room for many many years so thank you
for inviting me back so thank you also
for the introduction
I keep Pradesh's right I've been
somewhat involved with with governments
recently a little bit in the US
government and
morosely a lot of Indian government and
also occasionally in Beijing - so apart
from just dabbling a little bit in the
valley but mike-mike startup days are
over
so today's talk is about there's no
technology in my place talk it's all
about what's happening in 5g let me just
call it the politics of IG and and any
research is just beginning to happen so
I'll kind of give you an idea of what's
going on where it's going what the
challenges might be and so on and so
forth so you know I think most of us all
loaded by gee it seems to be there
everywhere it's on it's on 60 minutes
it's an PBS it's a New York Times so so
so I guess all of you heard of it a
million times so today I'm going not
comment a little bit about probably in
particular a view from somebody's
throwing
these things at Parker the technology
level partly the political level so I
hope I'll be able to transmit some new
idea a new information to you and thank
you for coming
let me spot started saying that what's
the killer app trillion and the Clara
pill is Wireless no Wireless has made an
incredible impact on our country and on
the world and in a personal Wireless
today we have smartphones but we started
off with these analog phones some years
ago but I landed at Stanford 91 for many
years I never had a fall but you know I
meant a new technological my more
anybody has heard of my mo mi mo yeah
it's every time use your phone now using
my mo I the Wi-Fi or an LTE so it's a
very fundamental technology but people
who story kid missing you don't have a
phone but nevertheless right now 98% of
the world's population have a phone and
about 40% have a smartphone today and
and of course the ID number in India I
spent a lot of my time in India and when
I left India in 91 we were we are less
than 13 million forms but we are
probably about 800 million people
there's 30 million phones so its
penetration was less than 5% and sorry
love came came around 1990 98 99 it
started moving within 10 years we were
at 98 percent so we went from 5 percent
98 percent within 10 years so that's a
transformation India but it happened in
China and Africa and certainly in the
United States - and there's always a
story shall I'm elected repeat there was
a company called Anderson consulting
company which was in so back in back in
nineteen in the 1980s they were cough
cellphones but they were car phones they
were basically you're either piece of
electronics back of you to give you a
car or in a bag put it in the front seat
plug it into the cigarette lighter and
pick up and make a call and they were
pretty expensive so you I think 18 t is
commissioned Anderson to do a survey of
what will be the number of
cellphones coverage cell phones in the
West meant to buy year 2000 and the end
of that millennia and they predicted was
1 million forms we were actually at more
than hundred million I think so things
can go badly wrong so the value of
phones is called mobility I mean all
these are video so what's the young
people it is completely obvious but it
wasn't obvious for the older guys like
me ease of access you can see it anytime
anywhere
the reach it could now retreat just the
remotest part of India or Africa
you can everybody in the world today has
a form and can get these voice
connectivity scalability you can drive
it no we can we can build we can no
software support seven billion people
ease of deployment this is an important
thing I remember his writing papers
about it you were right you were doing a
wide net flow you got run over to every
home I maybe some people may not even
subscribe to that that connection
whatever reason so a lot of dead
infrastructure when cell phones are very
put up whatever use each baggage guy
buys his own phone so it's a much more
the point is far faster and fauns
and much lower cost I think and cost of
avoids access in the u.s. was hard to
say but I think it is something like
close $1,000 phones brought it down
dramatically by a factor of 10 or 20
times so so it's been a huge huge
benefit so Phi T is corrupt we'll bring
this these and more benefits to sensors
actuators machines and and that'll
enable you think much much better data
analytics AI and ultimately industry 4.0
so this the fight is going to bring all
these wonderful benefits from voice of
phone cover of phone access to to do two
objects sensors actuators IOT machines
and so on so forth so that's the big
picture on fight G so this is a I wrote
a report to the government of India and
five year and this pictures from from
that report so basically 2g was a basic
phone I need to remember all these you
know you buy a phone all these
technologies still inside the mix of
five
not be yet that popular in us but 2 3 &
4 GF every foreign body phone has all
these systems so this thing that seem to
go away but the 2g was just a basic
phone and I think I finally bought a
phone and wrong 1998 the first time in
Stanford and reimburse phones those days
then the 3G phone so it's kind of
feature phones did some emails and dice
to have my first company about having a
blackberry in pink lilac and 4G was it
really brought in concept smart phones
Android and bi and Apple iOS systems and
then of course now data became much much
better faster and you can do a lot more
things that phones and this is what we
have today
fight fight G is also another G so it's
more more speed all these things sort of
added fun functionality to phones yg
will do that of course but also many
many other things many other
applications which I'll talk about IOT
and transportation manufacturing and so
on so it's a real whole lot in your
applications so it's much more than
another G so much of the excitement of
ideas because got that top layer it can
do many more things
I'll talk quite a lot about that but
that's the Wi-Fi she has so much of
stuff behind it in a such a and I should
also say that usually when 2g was around
when when 3G was coming everybody said
we don't need another G maybe we'll do a
little and I remember 4G I was a deeply
involved 4G I had two companies in the
area and you know I was part of the
technology because my mode which is the
fundamental to it was what I was
inventor people didn't think 4G will do
anything much they think it's just way
of selling more phones but transformed
everybody's lives you know there's no
way one kind no considerable living of I
can even think of a word without 4G
today so Phi G in other hand has caught
a lot of hype behind it first time you
seeing something where people are saying
that this is going to be really big so
let's see but you plays out
so this is our the busy slide and the
Americas so sort of talks about all that
fight you might do is a transformational
fabric and if we look at most of the
reports from the United Nations actually
they all talk about how transformational
5g will be its rule of law in the future
and I think it'll they'll probably
fulfill its promise but there are three
buckets in five years likely not right
not extreme but enhanced mobile
broadband basically higher speed access
to phones and other devices is just like
cellular system but much higher speed
second one is massive scale computing
this is like IOT connecting to lots of
sensors and actuators millions of them
and the third one which is actually the
most interesting is making
communications more reliable and low
latency that will enable a lot more new
applications so these are the three
important buckets
it'll be run through a few of them if
you have enhanced broadband certainly
you can certainly do much better video
calling and virtual meetings and it
turns out that today most US homes I'm
on campus I have fibre most of us don't
have fiber in homes and with DSL or with
with cable you don't it can't have to
cross 100 hundred megabits by now in a
real reasonable way but yg can bring
gigabits to your home so Phi G is going
to become a big enabler of fixed
wireless and so and then of course now
there are verticals here human human so
those are virtual reality video calling
variables social networking public
safety so Phi G will enable this along
these horizontals human to machine
so things like augmented reality fixed
wireless smart homes healthcare
monitoring and finally
machine-to-machine which is really that
the big thing that's going to much
bigger than these two verticals all
kinds of things from video monitoring
mobile cloud computing to industry 4.0
it's going to enable this whole whole
idea of new form of industry with
sukhothai cyber physical
customs vehicle-to-vehicle
communications smart agriculture smart
everything so it's going to be big thing
so this is the high-level picture of Phi
G so let's look at what's happening in
standards and deployments in wireless it
turns out you need standards because
phones made by different people and and
infrastructure pieces are made by
different people we want to talk to each
other they're too big strict standards
and I remember in Phi G Phi max I was
really involved with IMAX very deeply we
spend about 50 million dollars building
that standard it might have been for
three fits stack of paper I think the
numbers in for 4G were much higher I
would suspect it hundreds of millions of
dollars so so it's a whole process by
which large teams thousands of people
meet every every month all over the
world and build a standard is full of
competitive issues standard central
pattern it's a very big game but lots of
ideas come in and the best ideas get
chosen so these standards are very
complex but also know in extremely
capable because they deliver all these
services so the 5g this the the
standards started were released 13 after
release 12 was LTE so released 13 will
is 14 at least 15 early 16 so released
15 has been now finally finalized I
think a few months ago really 16 is now
in process and that team called early
drops it means initial drops or the
standard but I think it will get always
finalized end of 2020 so I've got that's
a little up little optimistic so I think
in the later end of 2020 with one more
release called release 17 which is in
preparation so that will start fairly
soon but probably get pushed out to 2021
now so that's a standard so it's
released 16 is now active but the
monthly meetings all over the world to
keep running around and you go - may I
be in the few of the ether you'll find
several thousands of people and no so
the deployments are just started phase 1
which is the
my boil broadband which is basically
another G data started I talked about
who's doing what but fundamentally is
it's China is leading the game here with
the maximum high speed with the most
deployments the United States is a
strong follower up Japan South Korea I
think these are the four big names
others and Europe not will will probably
be little later I wanted to mention that
in 4G 4G was largely not key I just came
from from from United States so 4G we
really let the you know us led the world
in Phi G we all of us know that an
infrastructure side Huawei has actually
become the leader and in deployment you
us-led China by about two or three years
but deployment in Fiji I think China's
when the lead in other states so that
has flipped so so that's a maybe
deployment the phase two and phase three
are these massive connectivity and ultra
reliable low latency communications they
are not even the standards not yet
completely frozen go there I'm optimist
to say 21 22 maybe a little longer so so
right now what be a big very very
beginning of EMV be the other two parts
of the probably more important pieces or
not it started so technology evolution
just put by gene perspective 1g was
analog and and the first 1g services
around 1984 85 they were the tough
phones when you had these electronics
and cars or back phones and and it
really changed thanks to some thanks to
the development of a smartphone of their
of the handheld phone till the end until
then you were us you stuck to the car
through a big bag and that was one of
the well known name behind that is Marty
Cooper well I got little the company
with them at one time
so so that idea of having a handheld
phone really changed the world but 1g
was there and then it was an unlocked
system FM modulation then 2g came around
late 1980s but actually deployment start
a little later
and it came from then we went
digital
first with her it's all analog
modulation analog system and digital
after 2 G & 2 in 2g and 3G the circuit
switched that means you set up put a
line and it remained with you the whole
the whole circuit remained with you till
it will call this torn down and the
initial 2g system no GSM was a TDMA
system you had a good slice up time and
give reached each time slice to a
different person a different different
form and and then we had CDMA where you
would actually do is called spreading
code and give a a unique code to every
person there was a big fight between TD
main CDMA and lots of they were I think
this room there was standing fight on
that issue remember because the Ericsson
was one camp and Qualcomm another camp
went on in Stanford those days 25 years
ago around those two battles of course
those those those technologies are long
gone so those battles are dead but CDMA
was was or the 3G system and then 4G
brought in a new technology and I was
involved with both those pieces idea of
OFDM I'll talk about it later was
invented actually in Bell Labs 1960s and
my more was actually came as was my
patent and so my moto FDMA that
combination became the the key
technology for 4G it's going to be in
fight jihad in Fiji it's part of my fine
now so it's a very very fundamental
approach to communications and it may
never go away it's well the earlier
systems sort of disappeared
so my modem a was was a very very
fundamental advance and I had a lot of
lot of plane that whole thing this is
ghost goes back to 1998 99 2000 and we
brought in smartphones and then because
now because this data we become packet
switched so these were data circuits
packet switched and Phi G is exactly the
same thing ma'am OFDM a
made me a little more flexible larvae
not that much changes I'm waiting
mentioned that later and then under g'd
most part phones but also new things IOT
and low latency ultra reliable stuff so
this is a big picture of technology
evolution and if the complexity of
analog systems was will I see the two
inch thick stack of paper fighter you'll
probably be 10 foot stack of paper it's
enormously complex systems and anybody
who's not under the hood and taking part
these standards will not and will roll
in and then realize how complicated
these things are so yeah what about
technology lifespans and you know 1g
probably really began to get deployed
and around 1919 sent people who would
buy phones and use them it's not a
lasted for about almost 15 years 2g
started around I would say late 1990s
and that's GSM and that's still around
that's not gone so it's it may never go
in my opinion but it's sort of expected
by 2020 by 2025 so it'll sort of taper
off but I would say for for three or
four billion people as well only only
have to G axis so it's still a very
critical in Africa and Asia certainly
Africa and in India and other other
places 3G came as to trying to give
better speed more Technium working more
efficient getting more calls it sort of
evolved a little bit in the data and
these really started applying around
2005 didn't last that long because it
was delayed initially because lack of
phone no phones available and then when
4G visage was so much better
it kind of been dying a very fast at now
so I don't think it will it'll have a
full 15 year or 20 year lifetime so 4G
now's the ruling technology the small
holders have notified he hasn't come to
San Jose so Santa Clara San Francisco so
4G is the rolling technology and it's
going to be gone it became in u.s. still
began to grow around 2012-13 and now
it's got large penetration
and it'll probably be around for another
20 20 25 years guy is going to be long
so last time and fight is just just
beginning if I heal will will go on till
probably to 2014 so these things take a
long time to grow and mature so that's a
big picture and Technology lifespans
the thing is that any any boy phone you
buy today goodbye a five-fold they have
5 4 3 & 2 g and way it works is we get
fighty access you go on fight you guys
fastest don't get that it dropped to 4G
don't get down you dropped 3d and you
don't get that you go back to 2 G so
these phones do all those things so
called multi red okay so let's what are
the barriers to getting getting these
revolutions launched and in case of
enhanced broadband with the 5g
high-speed files already there's just
another phone everybody understands what
the phone is so it's matter buying a 4G
phone and we are selling 50 phones in
the United States from LG and from
Samsung and but it generally around the
world one of the barrier optical
spectrum options family India but I go
back over there last week we are still
on allocated spectrum so live alone
getting the other thing ready and
there's recent by spectrum a prospective
in delayed because fight fighters uses a
new spectrum called millimetric band and
government don't understand the
economics of that properly so it's been
delayed I know it's the availability of
phones and devices or ample I think
Apple still hasn't come up with a phone
here we still have these Samsung Samsung
and LG phones
mostly and in 3G / ample even in 4G
those delays in the deployment because
their lack of devices it turns out the
infrastructure in slightly easier than
the phone but I think if IG
infrastructure also going to be more
delayed because cells are small and more
expensive
before the it's such a cost is going to
be higher and though Verizon and AT&T do
a lot of happy talked about deploying
widely is going to be very expensive cuz
cells are pretty small but in general I
would say the auction's phone device
availability infrastructure the leader
today is China though they are moving
much
very fast but they're good there they
are deploying in a band called the 3.5
and I'll talk about that so what's new
in Taiji well you know certainly new
applications new spectrum if we've gone
to a complete new band so that's a lot
of learning to be done there we still
get to learn a lot it's going to be much
denser network many more cells in that
for densification and then some Phi G is
moving towards a different form of
implementations got NFV the idea that a
building specific hardware to run the
fight a network we're just going to use
server farms blades and just alright
soften them and that's called aura and
lock happening they're you know they're
thousands hundreds of thousands of
companies doing it but I just sort of
squint get most softer eyes in the way
it does things and it's going to enable
things like data as they cry and a
mobile edge computing which Prasad Asha
talked about in fact which is the series
that's being launched here ok so the
first thing is frequency bands so Phi T
has got sort of will come in three bands
one is the low frequency band 700
megahertz mid frequency bands this is a
three point four to three point eight
gigahertz sometimes called a CBR S band
or something called sub six band and
then the high frequency band which is
the twenty four twenty eight and thirty
nine Giga gigahertz these are the
millimetric band these are much much
higher frequencies typically they were
never considered useful for cellular but
we have it's coming in and interesting
how it's playing out so generally the
the millimetric band will be used in
very large scale you know we highly high
ten servants certainly stadiums will be
a great place for it
you could also be used for in dense
downtown's Patterson Patterson areas so
when you want to lock to speed and lots
of capacity while the mid frequency
bands which are the blue ones will be
will will support traditional
traditional alt-tab applications mobile
mobile communications fixed wireless
probably and actually
hi thickens banter also for fixed
wireless and the and the high frequency
bands are fundamentally for fixed
wireless and for for this applications
and I'm sorry low frequency bands are
for much larger cells and also for IOT
it turns out IOT the problem that IOT is
that these are small devices the button
batteries will last for many many years
and it turns at lower frequencies can do
a better job of getting the penetration
done I'll talk more about that later so
that's the low band is the IOT band the
mid band is traditional for heat up
applications the high band is high-speed
access for homes and mobiles and dense
areas and the spectrum you know we're
expecting doesn't get allocated in one
shot it is an intuitive process so every
country is trying to add more spectrum
Europe mid band low bandwidth ban high
band the United States was one of the
leaders in allocating high band spectrum
they still we're still adding more but
we are the first country in the world to
put saying they're going to do this make
it happen a lot of skepticism we won't
make it happen we allocate a spectrum
and Verizon and AT&T are deploying that
now I think Sprint will follow up to up
to a point and some other players too so
so essentially the China Korea Japan the
US are the leading guys and in spectrum
in deployment and but this is a case of
process but this one major difference
between China in the United States China
ago did allocate high band spectrum it's
decided or in I don't even
alakay I option them it's actually
moving forward with rolling out in the
mid band that is the three point five to
three point four point zero ban u.s. had
another hand allocated high band
spectrum and we actually rolling out in
that band and there's been a lot of
discussion in Washington which I've been
a little bit power
saying that is that a wise thing to do
because at Iban you get a lot of
bandwidth but the cells are much smaller
is going to be much slower and deploying
well China will have to run to deploying
much much faster because cells are
larger and you know I have some views
that I won't necessarily share with you
but there's there's this discussion
going on but eventually both countries
will deploy both spectrum question is
who leads in what first okay an India
Graham somewhat involved with we haven't
done a we haven't you know I act wrote a
committee report recommending certain
bands but the government hasn't
auctioned them okay
Sybilla metric band is the completely
new band we always all our phones at the
most work in the 2.5 gigahertz band we
know you're talking about 39 gigahertz
and so what's new about that
so the bands are 24 28 37 39 us sitting
has three of those bands 24 not yet been
auctioned the in general there's one
gentle hit against millimetric band -
band is there's more loss in the band
that is not true actually photons it's
fly exactly the same way through normal
air whether it's one gigahertz or
particular there's no loss the real loss
comes from a different different via
different problem and I'll explain that
so but in general in a millimetric band
you you have to have an array of
antennas to form a beam otherwise you
can't get any range and therefore you
normally have been forming and you tend
to form very narrow beams so in general
you only talk we from the array from
that base station to the phone there
must be a direct line of sight sometimes
you can have one bounce of the we have a
nice tall building can bounce off that
but you kind of sort of there was no
spreading and scattering that doesn't
work very well so you need to have line
of sight or near line of sight a little
thought there's no really loss in
frequencies in free space but high
frequency has a bad rap for saying
loss and low range weight of the low
range come from I'll explain that next
slide so in deployment generally smaller
you can't get no Phi kilometres cells
cell sizes are 200 to 400 meters
and it turns out that if you take an
omni antenna at 39 gigahertz omni
antenna another Omni at 39 go ahead
they won't even could have any put the
same power let's say 23 DBM for a DBM we
can't even close the link off the table
don't even go 5 feet so you want to go
further you got to put you have to put
an aperture and my next slide might
explain that a lot of even engineers who
know a lot of stuff get this wrong so
there's no real absorption 30th band or
28th will not go through trees so you'll
have 25 15 DB loss in a tree but if you
don't have trees fall eh you can fly
very very well as long as you can do the
one the right thing the problem here is
this is that widest range fall with with
which frequency is this suppose this is
a phone
transmitting 23 DBM there's got a watt
whether it's 1 gigahertz or 30 gigahertz
you're sending out photons we've got a
water photons now the at the base
station you I would have a receiving
antenna which has certain beam with a
horizontal and vertical it have to have
certain numbers in order to make things
work it turns out that antenna at 1
gigahertz a pretty large antenna so it
catches a lot more photons at 29
gigahertz antennas tiny antenna it
doesn't catch the same photon so that's
the reason why you don't you have
perceived loss there's no real loss
antennas are the apertures to say yeah
the cross-section cutting and clearance
is small so the way you do it now is you
put a lot of antennas and then casually
encima more photons and then we do beam
forming and then you can get the ranges
so fanatical you have a 20 by 20
centimeter array and it's a transmitting
33 DBM that's 20 watts of power you will
find that at but in 3.5 24:28 39 this is
this is the low by mid band and those
the high bands the cell rate is doesn't
drop that much 16 20 meters to 380
meters but the price of doing that is
you need to have a large number of
antennas this is a 5 by 5 array and you
need 55 by 55 in fact I think most of
rays we build today don't don't have
close to 20 by 20 maximally thing so you
may not get the ATM
you land up with 250 meters or so but as
long you don't you go through wet trees
lots of foliage high bands are not
necessarily that bad in ranges but you
got to have a raise and you need to have
be falling and folds also will now have
to have multiple antennas a small array
and turning the phones will be hard that
already so it's possible
everything works okay now let me talk
first about the first the the G part of
5 G what's happening well it's just
another G service 2 phones CPEs now
that's a fixed file it's fixed wireless
you put a little either put a little
table top stuff in your window or come
down something outside but fix - is a
big part of the use case Falls suddenly
and find your phones around available I
know in Chicago you can use them and my
fire my fire is the device that most of
us have it you jump in on mobile you
jump on Wi-Fi keep in the car looking so
a lot of Wi-Fi these devices coming
where you can actually get gigabit into
that bar into that little box and you
can jump off Wi-Fi so you can the speeds
are pretty phenomenal 2 gigabits dude
2020 will be pretty small pretty very
very small cells but can get very high
speeds not all of them are available
today but they will get there you know
LT typically is about up to but for and
refined in megabits but this one is good
if any gigabits it's initially there's a
mode called
non stand-alone that means you can't
really have a pure fight you phone you
got to make a fighter and a 4G
connection simultaneously to to deal
with all the control issues so later on
we will go to SAS and alone so that's an
evolution is happening the new radio is
a MIMO OFDM radio it's got a little bit
of flexibility around that and they call
it enough IGN our radio and the
remarkable thing is the weather you
using 600 megahertz of 439 gigahertz the
same radio so it's called in our radio
it it they EMB be part is generally
deployed in the mid band in high pan
China's mid band us in high pan or they
will of course
do what eventually the lower band is
used for Aliotti I mentioned that
earlier
in general the feeling is that the cost
per bit for delivering a bit will be
much lower 20 times that can lower than
for G so that's the economic sort of
argument for Phi G in this mode another
G mode and I think us we deployed many
many cities I do know in Chicago but
there are several others if six fathers
axis is actually considered to be a very
important use case in the United States
because of cable and DSL then it nor
don't deliver that much you want gigabit
like I have at home thanks to fiber you
don't going to get it from those
technologies so so wireless can do it
for you
so this is becoming pretty important use
case and I think I think they're rolling
out fixed file is also in United State
we have in fact in Dallas so delivers
gigabit mail speed so it's remarkably
high speeds it'll do it to a CPU
terminal gather outside sometimes we
cannot get a good range otherwise
hopefully inside on the kitchen table on
your the window Verizon AT&T are rolling
out in the US but you can't have too
many trees you know foliage is a problem
for these bands so you want to avoid
heavy foliage and this politics because
there's a big deal month or Gigabit
access to home there are other companies
like we linked cuz I'm involved with
also trying to do similar stuff at 60
gigahertz so it's not true Phi G but
there's lot happening here now so so
fixed iris axis I think in ten years
from now most of you will get gigabit
and it will be Wireless in your home so
what where are the phone you know
subscriber thing these is a chart from
Canales analysis
so right now beyond 2019 I think the
there are 30 million phones I think us
may have very few maybe half a million
million at the Muslims those phones are
probably in China where things are
moving faster but you can see that as we
go along China will have the certainly
larger population so by another three
years China however to answer to three
million phones
I believe in China today half the faults
being sold today in China are fighting
abled in the United States so it's much
much smaller it's probably only over one
to three percent so if China has gone
much faster in to fight G so not America
and that is will be to be there so the
so so this will so at some point this
will start eroding into I think LT will
keep going I think IG will really start
a roading for the LT growth only about
five six years from now forever for
right now for G still use the growth
phase so what about equipment and this
has been lots of discussion in the West
US and in China and in India about who
manufactures home and what are these
lava vulnerabilities and so on so forth
so pretty that the dominant vendor for
Phi G if we in price were we and what
this number is 2023 I think it won't
happen but do any fancy who are we may
be in a bigger trouble than this today
they are the dominant eye I think
typically similarly as follows Ericsson
is smaller Nokia is even smaller and
then lots of others there is ZTE from
China and a little bit from Samson is
used in India for example and and there
are others too NEC in Japan so I'm so
forth
but whoever is the leader and and
certainly put a lot of investment into
technology I fairly good understanding
of competitive values of these three
guys and I can't share that here and
this is on the ranch site at the Radio
Network there's also the core network is
called EPC which is where the core way
all the boxes like doing your hand overs
and all that so there are the you'll
notice there's no US companies in this
in this in this layer which is very
unfortunate we don't have any companies
in the United States in the ranch side
you know all the companies that we had
if somehow have died or been absorbed by
other foreign companies with no rent on
the EPC cosine we Slav Cisco we have a
few other smaller companies but
again Ericsson huawei Nokia are the
three big big players in cisco has a
role to perspective handsets it's now
largely us Apple is still not come out
as lot gun got clock and they'll do it
fairly soon I think but but ZTE and
Huawei is 80 I think are the dominant
but the university of their blocks or LG
and Samsung or so the universe also John
is ami another Chinese company and
another sent mentioning for half the
phones sold in China may not be today
but certainly by January will be Phi J
enabled that's an amazing amazing
achievement so what about the other part
of the non ji Parvati IOT low-latency
Alto rather fabric fabric got some
largely the more interesting part and
it's going to impact many many things so
it's just just a buzz cloud let's talk
about what about deployments of this
part this is going to be phase 2 and
phase 3 the IOT part and and I and the
other arrival part you know I put it at
21 and 22 this is no report in India I
think this is going to get pushed out a
little bit more I'll explain why so this
is much harder to do bigger than in
fight G for the EMV be part is just
another phone people understand what it
means and what it brings but here we are
turning into new areas so it's going to
be slower than we think
so what are the barriers here lots of
question use cases many many mostly new
use cases I need to be built we talk
about things loosely but I mean what
often companies where we find it takes a
long long time to penetrate make things
happen so first of all it's a new class
of devices and applications so
everything is new so it takes time to to
get it done but also simply often
customized you built one fan for Samsung
builds half the falls in in Vietnam just
by the way Vietnam this year will be I
think doing something like more than one
hundred billion four hundred billion
dollars or folks
half the phones are built merely they
sell it all over the world but then when
you do IOT in all that it's highly
specific to a particular box a
particular country it's much more
customized so it's not that scalable and
often live what I noticed for my board
positions is that it's difficult to push
these things into industries because
you've got to change so many processes
within the system with lots of
resistance so it takes time to adopt so
this part is so however promising is
going to take time against there's many
more barriers affecting and so you
talked a little bit about one thing the
series is all about this is a mobile age
computing so what is the way that what
about smaller engine copulating
basically instead of taking all your
data back to the cloud you'd put a box
nearby and and then therefore from your
from data ever made sources from you
would go to the edge which means the
local box you would do some processing
there and then you will suffer stop the
cloud but you will do much bigger things
there so what is the big big role of MSC
well latency already 5g will take us
eventually to about one millisecond
latency on the air today it's about 10
to 20 milliseconds but you don't want
then go 200 order miles to a cloud point
you want to be able to get to this in 50
feet - it can be processed or you can be
served so mobile if the low latency is
critical for making 5 G's the low
latency useful so edges one much of that
second thing data localization you know
people who don't want data to leave a
premises university or a factory so by
processing data locally it made free
curves and also there's a security
element to this is linked to
localization you don't want to data to
be exposed to outsiders and more and
more data being used consumed
I mean extracted worked on with
analytics and you go back and feed the
system back in the react to it you want
that fast turnaround whether it's a
store or whether it's in a factory
all this semi see makes sense so we'll
see a lot of lectures in the series
which will which will expand on these
ideas IOT
this has been a long and
coming I think we've been taught
morality for more than ten years and
again it's been slow to develop it's
been most autistic still haven't have
happened the reason for that is what I
mentioned before because these things
tend to get embedded heavily into the
processes of file systems and it's not
easy to change things so it will take
time but there are lots of already
current players bluetooth is there
there's Laura there's igby and in your
home you have all these things in your
home anyway so finally is a new player
in the block but it tend to be for
outdoor focused a lot of indoor stuff is
going on which I find you won't touch
daily and the the definition of what
Feige will do is being done it really
sixteen it'll get done bit to summer
2020 so what a fight you're going to do
in IOT is to pay much more attention to
battery conservation the idea today is
you know most of you have sensors in
your home and you have to change a
battery every three months idea of Phi G
is to put a button battery and use it
for ten years
that requires a lots of very clever
ideas the fight yield brings to all the
cleverness into it the main idea is sort
of sleeping make things sleep as much as
possible this victim up exactly for the
little bit to get the data out of them
so that requires lots orchestration so
if I didn't bring not so much in the air
interface but in is in the scheduling
part lots of very smart things certify G
will be a big player in in IOT but it's
going to take time
what about a I will know you can't
escape AI being at Stanford but one is
the as increasingly using delivering 5g
fabric it turns out with ample already
AI is coming in I'm not talking about
city just the AI is coming in into
making the the wireless links work
better or make scheduling work but it's
just in the middle layer one layer to I
began to play a role in fact there's a
conference next next within 10 days in
Europe which Angwin is peaking at
talking a little bit about those issues
it's also coming into infrastructure to
make infrastructure easier to debug is
it install optimized and then after the
global level when it went all the
networks
in a camp together we can do lots of
lots of optimization across networks oh
yeah is the enabling Phi G and it's
never really never played the role in 40
so Phi G it's begun to play a role and
I'm surprised to see the amount of
progress made it a lot of remarkable
progress made in the lower levels which
I'm aware of is pretty remarkable and of
course AI lost enable enables many
things it's basically a fabric which
will bring in AI applications and then
of course bring in lots of new
industries and we know all about that
the AI is two roles in nothing I think
both those are beginning and and but I'm
pretty surprised to see what how well
it's already doing at what bottom layer
their manufacturing yes again because
there's a wireless arts many many
benefits know much more location
flexibility can move things around you
know most of all I remember when I did
my companies we would wire the entire
company for for for internet access you
don't do that anymore so you get at a
wiring and of course you have to be this
time they are extremely super super
super reliable and low latency to make
sure these things work properly much
more reconfigurable but analytics
integration analytics and emission
analytics so this is something called
industry 4.0 where AI would be a big a I
am EC not ever being used a fight fabric
to transform industry and I think
there's lots of promise here but it's
still still still out in the future we
it's not mainstream as yet and then the
force of a vehicle to X vehicle to
anything intelligent transportation
totally safety will be a big part of it
can you loosen congestion smart routing
this we're seeing already a little bit
in for gene but it will become much
bigger there was an effort in Stanford
which I was part of where we were
looking at 4G for doing these sort of
things but finally was he never embraced
properly so Phi G will embrace this
properly their standards and his
efficiency autonomous driving whenever
that happens but they're also also other
standard
in play called SRC a night replace a
fight is not the only player who's got a
muscle and seeing whether all the
investments happening here will actually
stay or yeah even if I feel takeover is
not entirely clear and so summary so
we'll be in service for another twenty
fifteen years minimum I wish I would
pull you and say forty but it's going to
take time to mature maybe six to seven
years before it's really we see all the
applications visible development mobile
and fixed services just beginning
probably in us maybe stuff just a couple
of million customers may in the United
States in China a little bit more and
the real potential fight your license
services enabled by MTC mobile
machine-to-machine communications and
low low low low low latency is
reliability that's the big big area I
think you know Romberg giving a talk at
the indeed mobile Congress last year is
it you know only 1% of eventual Phi G
applications are now visible lot of it
is ahead many of you can start companies
to make that happen
in 2000 2005 when I was actually work
busy with WiMAX but my max is 4G LTE a
similar we are no no understanding all
this will happen there's no
understanding
so all thats came last ten years so
we'll be surprised at what what world
will do it for you but thank you
so it's really about abilities but this
Wendy's there's some elements so it was
security as many dimensions but it's
always this funny in saying that data
can be leaked out of a network you know
sort of forked out and this is always
the top position between Squa basic
where we could be doing it not that we
have shown anything as yet the so the
question is are the ways of protecting
that and detecting that there's actually
a committee sitting on a
stanford is involved with it open so
there's some attempt to try and bring
some some more thinking around that
problem of poking data but why so much
of security feel is is the failures of
unique voice fighty talk about security
so much as I fight evil
I'm started touching you know today
forty touches four hundred four billion
people fight he will touch trillion
things so opportunities but things going
wrong is much more so obviously you know
we systemic with my must must find a way
by which bad practices or sloppiness
this is control it usually stopping us
it creates problems how do you actually
detecting stop it so I think that it
will tell I think otherwise encryption
and authentication pretty good so I want
to ask about the cost of developing the
infrastructure for 5g because if you're
developing especially the high band of
5g where you have to have cell towers
every two or three hundred meters that's
a huge amount of cost and how can that
be covered I'm hoping that you will
recover your cost because there's enough
off take from it and so I think that's
that's the play everybody has certainly
in LTE
I can tell you the same issues showed up
fifteen ten years ago saying there's the
cell T cells are smaller because we're
using wider bandwidths whenever used by
the bandwidth just my mo helps a lot but
still still never never fully does it in
2g yeah I'm um in GSM you couldn't have
10 kilomettre cells it shrunk to one
kilometer Sdn everybody said that's not
going to work now he's going to go to
200 meters so I think it's a question of
making sure the enough application to
pull revenue and get customers to pay
for it so that's dance that I think so
far the radios the beam former radios
the physical layer there are pretty dumb
they're not really source of of getting
data now I think the real stuff is when
the data gets into the core that's where
a lot of many patient takes place and
also with connections outside world so
all the vulnerabilities are settings had
a core and that's that mischief can be
done the edges of the edge in wireless
is fundamentally the radio part and they
are likely to be much better behaved so
generally the view of today is that in
european is that if you have worried
about entity or country technology bring
them into the edge they're not going to
own that much damage but don't bring
them to the core till you're more
certain that things are okay so that's a
philosophy going on in europe the
technology stack you have all these
boxes they you know they're variety of
boxes even the code network for dvds
with subscribe identity with including
building all those horrible area okay
network they're not considered to be
vulnerable it's where you actually when
you when you start manipulating the
moving it around and connect his outside
world that's where you're probably going
to come so keep you know it's obviously
that's the in Europe instance yeah
saying that will be safe to bring though
not to bring suspicious players into the
core now okay and core would include
from the tower into the cloud yeah the
court up from the tower today it's going
to work is to the devil you already have
a radio yeah I'm alright then you pull
it back on what's called or rang and
then you come into a big civil thumb
where everything gets done all the
cofunction get done some of you even
some of the radio part gets that some of
the processing level layer gets done and
then that's where you connect to the
outside world it's there the potential
of vulnerabilities arise there okay so
you want to if you're worried about
those issues use use complete you trust
there but radio side is less this thing
there's a little but our angle to it it
turns out that is NSA and it's a non
standalone no one signed on means you
can you your file G connections also
quite a 4G connection so in on someone
mode you're going to continue to use
your current LT codes called the EPC Co
so already there and if you're happy
with it and safe it's safe so you can
actually roll out Phi G in NSA mode
without touching the current call which
is already safe therefore that's the
cast mate
people are going once you go to a same
mode then the call happy change and then
you have decisions about those issues
okay thank you go ahead basically why is
that and what are the kind of policy
implications for the government for the
next 460 so first of all I on
infrastructure side we have really no
plane I mean there's my small companies
but not real plane but on the phone side
you know the chips inside er your phones
to fight you phones will still have
Qualcomm in our radio and flap
come chips so so on the foot side we are
feeling strong but China has pretty much
similar similar strengths but on
infrasound
which is 0 the the problem I mean let's
not talk about China but but now state
though we had we had not L this is the
u.s. Canadian company they made some
terrible terrible mistake losing their
2000 internetwork and then they deserve
the diamond to die then we had loosened
which you know unfortunately didn't
quite work out so it merged with Alcatel
and that didn't work out then with
emerged with Nokia so now loosens
cordial footprint so you guys footprint
of Nokia is pretty small now so it's
become really a Finnish company so so I
think comparison I would say to China
China I think played its cards much
better and I mean I won't go into
details I mean know some of them but
fundamentally Huawei where now is
probably investing coming like 15
billion dollars of R&D a year in in yg
nothing like that happening in this
country so we have to step up and do
something about it
so I also want to follow up on that
because the standards organizations
behind 5g are international and they're
technically industry rather than
government correct now in that situation
if the US has such a small share of the
market in regard to 5g equipment and so
forth does that reduce American
technologies kind of contribution to the
sorry it happened in Fiji I think
something like I mean I could be wrong
but the dominant number of sets sepsis
standard essential patents is it's
Huawei probably dominant and I think it
mean as much as 50 percent so everybody
else is looking for that Eric since you
know Intel all the guys are playing on
the level 30 percent so always become
the dominant order of intellectual
property so you know so I you know we
have a real vulnerable to here in fact
you go into the Senate building you find
everybody wants to know what we're going
to do but there's a huge concern in in
our state saying is such a fundamental
fabric of the country there's we need to
do something or now if we don't have a
player yeah go ahead
the future of service providers regional
service providers do you think about 1%
of applications actually being visible
today it was fascinating new business
models are coming that's a good question
and I think you know I'm a little bit
involved with this issue at the
governmental level the thing is that one
two three forty phones
fighty the phone part look similar and
surprises know do what you know what
they're doing they can make things work
but other pieces are very you know and
and I don't think the service part is
the current service part is really know
the stuff well enough they don't have
the linkages in the industry so in
general my view is there is an
opportunity for new type of service
providers including some of these
networks will be private networks from a
big factory labs all networked and exalt
sort of so there's a lot of opportunity
I think for new service providers with
different business models to enter into
the non G part of our team and I'm not
I'm actually skeptical whether 18 all
these current companies will be able to
move there quickly enough I think
unlikely I think so if they don't do you
see companies that are likely to move I
think you know we can do startups and
yeah I'll figure that out but I must say
that that this second part the non G
part is going to take some time to boil
because it's called I've seen my own
stuff how difficult it is to bring them
in because of all these process changes
now Latium but but they will my opinion
this there's a lot of way out even and
even in Europe they did a lot of talk of
saying how do you invent new business
models which which
but for people who couldn't hear because
I know that it's hard to hear sometimes
mo you are talking about really open
source or open standards for hardware in
the networks usually you talk about open
source software but you're really
talking about hardware compatibility or
what do you mean by openness here
you personalize this something up
in the air make sure you have a whole
thing yeah actually I think that's a
very profound question and I want to
spend a little little time with it first
of all yeah I'm not doing a flow search
computing but but if you have one is on
the hardware side that I've seen you
know people actually trying to put this
it's you know there's nothing more than
just a server with some data by the
memory Atlee into a piece none the
vilest a piece so it's all sort of
things are happening they're putting
these boxes because it was a big part of
a champion is to find power for it
so already have something using power is
easy to push them in there but
respective point I think because that
she was talking about was really the
what about the interface protocols and
sound are they from there so that box
can missing mix and match I think in
that's probably I don't I'm not really
sure but most probably just be taken up
by industry consortiums and try and come
up with voluntary standard there's not
happening I'm not close to it actually
the way I want to follow up with this is
do you see the International
communication situation breaking down
into different regional factions so that
a 5g phone here will not work somewhere
else you know I think that the big
Berlin wall is going to be if you know
if you say Indochina you know us-china
issue and so they were so I see lots of
dangers there because if China is pushed
out of standards and not exactly they're
going to create their own ecosystem and
that's really not good for anybody but
that's a couple of layers of a scalable
my levels of comment on it although I am
kind of impressed just from your
presentation so different frequencies in
different countries and so the
telephones already have to have
that can cope with all of these
different frequencies and now you may
have different kinds of protocols that
they have to have different chipsets and
I remember the old days when American
versions of networks didn't match the
European GSM he's and that was bad
enough but I really wonder if this is
going to be a huge issue with 5g because
of the complexity is so much more well
Janet probably is heating a little bit
of its own cake because some of some
years ago it did build something called
td-scdma have a little bit involved with
and then they forced any way anybody
selling phones that stuff and put a
penalty and everyone and no there's the
focus to shoes on the other foot now for
it I say that putting pull back okay go
ahead the two issues we didn't see
connected in actually implementing
something that you do
easily the cost of flight security
second data actually being utilized what
it allowed to actually enable
decision-making to make us smarter fit
your presentation it looks like with the
cost second of get down to you know one
twentieth of what they are today with
bungee that's going to happen next
end-user so what is the right time for a
new company to start designing products
for these ecosystems where the
proliferation of the network is strong
enough so that your timing is difficult
questions but when I mentioned that 20 X
reduction in cost per bit I was talking
about telephone services for phones say
no because the bid will come down I
think in the the cost of it may not be
the right metric in case are your teeth
or tough you're talking about they made
other metrics there and certainly you
know battery you know longevity don't
want to be changing changing batteries
too often and security there may be
other drivers there but but I do my own
sense is that there's going to be a huge
opportunity now and lots of lot of
things are happening and a lot more
things will happen smaller so can you is
in some ways trade-off one is the other
meaning
yeah bandwidth always that unfortunately
costs power but some of these things
don't require much power much much data
to send and therefore you don't need
much bandwidth so did the real the
tricks about low slow low power is
really the scheduling things that is you
know now IOT really has something to
send some sense invent it must get
access to the network if it actually the
way today a phone does this it actually
sends the wracked oppressed with
billions of bytes take place before
phone can actually talk I hope they can
afford all that so there's the system
called a some techniques called SEMA and
what is the other one
no rod Robert is to baste full because
it will keep on touching people who
don't want to talk so you'd only want so
that some new techniques and I it's
neither talk but new ideas by which
somebody wants to send only five bits
for once in a day at some random time
you can do it very very efficiently and
that doesn't work today in the current
network for G doesn't allow that fight
he's got some mechanisms by which these
guys can get in the system and actually
talk and get out so encounter fight a
IOT is all about power reduction really
back in the back
I would agree I mean so cameras are you
know are different animals so they they
don't they can't send a few bits and
require and and this and be happy so
cameras yes cameras will be a use case
for Fiji where you do need you need new
dean new the new dean bandwidth but but
I think why I would think most cameras
today we do get camera which are
battery-operated but you've got to
change the battery those big batteries
every two months most cameras will be
wired Y so the power may not be that
important for them before yeah before we
go too much for this I do want to put in
a plug for a future weeks in the course
because we have somebody who will be
talking about autonomous vehicles in a
couple of weeks we've got a panel later
on in the quarter we've got a panel
talking about highly interactive edge
devices like AR and games because this
is both video as well as extreme low
latency is required so we'll come back
to these issues
um go ahead yeah so I think I would
think you know the when separation say
I'm not talking about I'm not talking
about the proficiency of the
infrastructure that isn't Phi G has
something called massive MIMO and finds
of MIMO supposed to be green it means
for every bit that transmits it uses
less power could beam forming better
focusing on that so I'm not I'm not
talking about the device that other end
I think a lot of the power savings and
these devices come from very intelligent
protocols and and very scalable ban but
somebody wants to send only few bits
they don't need to talk on a FileMaker
file you may have up to hundred mega
challenge at 200 mega channels that be
impossible for them to talk on that they
got to talk on a few hot channel yg has
all this flexibility to deploy much
narrower channels much better scheduling
wakeup times and so lots of intelligence
there so I think the sheer of I know
because the people participate but if I
leave like the best ideas to try and
reduce increase battery life yeah so
it's a complicated issue you know Japan
we don't we started forgive it for free
it's called beauty contest
I think the disease of oxygen spectrum
started from the United States and as
they have make me money the the
typically I know a little bit more India
the problem is that if you have an
option people really can't see the
future and sometimes they over bid and
that kills the company companies have
died in India because they over bid on
the spectrum it's happened here in the
US also and and so so so another hand
there you don't want to you know giving
fee may not work
in the United States but so you want use
put a base price that base price is too
low there may be some collusion so there
are experts in Stanford and the whole
life worrying about how to do it
correctly but there is no silver bullet
in after all spectrum is public you know
it's a common so it's a public space and
it should be used for the public good
the question is how do you do it right
there's no I think there's no good way
to do it every country finds his own way
and India of a little bit involved with
policy I think we're still figuring out
because the current base price I think
that we were offering in India to the
carrier's carry signal we don't get a
bit it's just too high and the question
is you know deal over it in which case
the public Exchequer won't get the money
so it's complicated that's a big problem
in India as you know import you know
what's going on we had used to have six
seven operators now there are three
obviously one is running this show that
other two are some level of distress so
yeah so know you know us is a better
shape we have at least two to three guy
three big guys and they're pretty good
we need that competition yeah got one
last question for you
sure so when I see on my cell phone
using a and T's AT&T service its
claiming that I've got five G yeah so
you know that's marketing and there's no
Phi G in the behavior thank you